so governor greg abbott of texas
he just deployed state law enforcement
to aid border patrol as migrants of
course flood across the border
the crisis is deepening for reasons you
may not have suspected
our own raymond arroyo joins us live
from the rio grande valley raymond it's
thundering and lightning here which you
may be hearing but what are you seeing
there
well we often hear that there's a human
crisis
at the border what i've found over the
last few days
is that that crisis may be coordinated
it's a combination of
biden's border policies and criminal
elements
as we discovered when we embedded with
members of the texas department of
public safety
their special ops division watch
stand on the banks of the rio grande in
roma texas on a weekend night
and there is a party literally on the
river
lieutenant christopher olivares is a
texas ranger
you can see there's cars numerous cars
just kind of just
you know driving around really no
purpose once it kind of dies down
clears out that's when you start seeing
the the criminal activity taking place
on this side
the river distraction rivals the water
show at the bellagio
and gives scouts a chance to scope out
quieter locations
up and down the river there's constant
traffic coming through here
we drove to a favorite cartel drop point
now patrolled by texas national guard we
waited in the dark
until 1am when the cartels started
moving migrants across the rio grande
they came and they came some more
you notice they're all tagged with bands
which is
operating procedure for the cartel
they literally tag these people
and not only are they clients of the
cartel
but in some cases they have to work off
their journey
once they're in america there's no doubt
they were brought here by the cartels
but
when questioned they won't speak at all
after dropping off these migrants the
smuggler returns
to mexico this is a business and
in many ways a deception a distraction
a human one up the road they are met by
border patrol
who now unable to patrol are forced to
register and transport
hundreds of migrants
due to the relaxed biden border policies
the surge of migrants
has increased and so is the power of the
unseen cartels
and once their processed border patrol
brings migrants here
to the respite center in mcallen it's
one of many faith-affiliated groups that
help
these migrants settle into america help
them find their destinations
and send them on their way it's a
problem for the whole country
they pass through here but they don't
stay here they come to
downtown mcallen then they're
transported out so
they pass through here and they're gone
so it's a it's a municipal issue to an
extent
but after that it's an issue for our
whole country the new mayor of mcallen
javier villalobos sees through the
cartels game
sometimes it seems like we're partnering
up with the cartels they bring them and
we assess
it's not right it doesn't seem right and
we've got to make sure
that the policies are changed whatever
they are what
they're doing right now is not working
laura the mayor is right the biden
policies at the border
really have turned border patrol into a
partner of the cartel an unwilling
partner
and that's why governor abbott had to
dispatch those thousand
of his own law enforcement people to
rebolster those efforts and fill in the
gaps
by the way border patrol has intercepted
or arrested
180 000 migrants
in the month of may tomorrow we're going
to tell you the real activity of these
cartels
what they're doing behind the scenes
it's frightening this is so
it's it's so shocking on so many levels
the adjectives don't even flow
at this point raymond it's both
heartbreaking
infuriating disheartening disconcerting
outrage i mean again the adjectives
don't capture it is a
human tragedy an economic disaster it
hurts our schools it hurts our health
care system
everyone feels bad for people who come
from bad countries where they
can't get a job or but that's half the
world they're being abused laura
of course those people are being abused
they're being sold a bill of goods
they're paying to come here
and then they're used by these cartels
sometimes they're used in the sex trade
other times they're they're used
illicitly through various criminals
yeah but our focus has to be on
our president is supposed to be
representing the american interest he
screwed it up over in europe
over the last few days now he's you know
ongoing
a crisis at the border that as as we
heard last week
described by the texas governor raymond
it's purposeful
they know what they're doing and it's
flood the zone with new people they want
new people coming into the country for
you know a variety of reasons
and that's what they want and that's
what they're getting two million people
will be here
these cartels yeah they're empowering
these criminal cartels
that's outrageous the report tomorrow
you won't want to miss laura
all right raymond thank you please uh be
careful there
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else